the jogan experience and you're going to
have to deal with that soon because I
guarantee you there's going to be some
people that are making some CG already
oh yeah I'm sure what is that I'm sure
there are yeah I haven't kept up with a
lot just cuz um you know I'm
doing so anything social media related
right now or anything any internet
presence I have right now is coming from
me off the phone just like before
everything blew up so I haven't invested
the time to like look at everything
circulating but I've people like friends
and family have sent me stuff and some
of it's pretty funny but uh you know
they've got all these different AI
remixes of the song with different
voices and um overlay different faces
and all and it's it's funny to see where
it's going to go you know that is funny
yeah you're going to have to deal with
that my daughter sent me some
advertisement she goes did you do this
advertisement I'm like nope nope that's
not really my voice it is my voice the
day after the day after things blew up
one of the towing companies had had an
ad on Facebook that had it it wasn't
really me but it was a red beard and
like the side profile of sunglasses
looking out the window I'm like okay how
dare you I guess I've made it anyway
that's when I realized like people are
already ripping things off and what's
crazy is like every shirt that I've worn
anywhere in public there's um so there's
a there's a organization that I've um
I'm not like officially related to or in
any way have done anything with but it's
a friend of a friend in the neighborhood
it's called Nets with vets and they take
out veterans with PTSD and let them go
deep sea fishing and so he asked me last
minute just to wear his shirt at one of
the concerts and do you know now there's
like 1500 listings online for
counterfeit Nets with vets shirts and so
the organization reached out like hey
are you like making shirts ripping us
off it's like it's not me so it's like
it's just it's a weird it's a weird
thing I've I've already experienced a
lot of that stuff not so much on the AI
side but just I don't know the
internet's just such a a Rowdy place you
know oh it's so rowdy the world's a
Rowdy place you it is and maybe people
bring maybe people bring their um their
best and their worst on the internet
like uh I've I've always tried to stay
off social media as much as possible but
um I've learned very quickly that like
Twitter and Facebook and stuff like you
you you see comments and feedback from
people both overwhelmingly positive that
maybe you wouldn't get in a personal
conversation but also like
overwhelmingly negative too you know
people just use that as a vent that just
they just take whatever seething hatred
they have inside of them they're like oh
I'm getting that guy with it you know if
you had a song Just About Love that
resonated like that it would be almost
impossible to hate you but you have a
song where you're talking about how
people are fed up with [__] and it
obviously resonated I mean I've seen
songs go viral but that's pretty banana
son your [__] your [__] went to the moon
right away and uh God I'm not sure who
sent it to me I have to find out who
sent it to me cuz it's one of those
things where like once one person sent
it to me then it was like dozens of
people were sending to me it it um it's
funny cuz originally that song wasn't in
my it wasn't really even in my top five
like it's not normally the type of song
I've written songs with similar messages
but as far as that sort of like I guess
Anthem format as what people are calling
it's like an Anthem like that's not
something I would normally write but uh
but it's an unlikely Anthem yeah know
insane times it would be an unlikely
Anthem yeah I had no idea that that song
would react the way it did at least in
my case I think the one thing that's
helped me to is that so my singing isn't
the best but I've never had any like
vocal lessons or anything so the way I
sing is just the way I sing and so like
I think even the same way with her and
other people it's like it's maybe Rough
Around the Edges it could be a little
pitchy or it's you know you're not using
the right part of your face when you
project and whatever and so like on
paper things aren't quite right but to
the I guess to another human it's like
it sounds like it sounds right cuz it's
it's it is it is what it is you know
it's authentic yeah yeah I don't think
there's any right way to do do anything
I mean there's like you see it in
everything there's a person who violates
the rules and they're the best at it and
then and then the rules almost morph
into whatever that is like um it's funny
like with music yeah music
has country in particular but music in
general has gotten way too wrapped up in
like this algorithm of how many beats
per minute it needs to have and how many
verses and how they need to be layered
and it's like they've almost created
this sort of like industry standard uh
like OSHA rule book of how music needs
to be performed and so like you can only
do that so many thousands of times
before people are like okay what else is
there you know well people like that too
that's the thing there's a lot of damn
people there's a lot of people the
problem I think with a lot of people is
they want you to like what they
like and if you don't like what they
like what you like
sucks it's it's funny like that man it's
we we're so tribal we we are we are
tribal with our our cell phones you know
we're an Android or PC you know Android
people stick together it's like we're so
weird we're so weird but we're like that
with our musical taste we we're like
that with our cultural sensitivities or
or or cult cultural sensibilities rather
like the way we feel about life and how
life should be we want everybody to kind
of think along the ways that we think
it's it's very strange and when a person
like yourself gets labeled a right-wing
leftwing fanatic like right out of the
gate both in both in like a week and a
half then yeah at least I know I'm doing
something right like to me yeah they're
they're looking for your biing campaign
contributions now they're going through
your [__] taxes it's the whole thing
is so Bonkers man like can't they just
accept that you made a great song and
people enjoy it why why does it h you
know why do people have to attack it
well I think it's just for whatever
reason I've been there's I'm the subject
matter the last couple weeks and I and
you know in everyone's defense I
probably haven't I've waited for for
this opportunity I guess to really have
a real conversation with somebody about
whatever it is I am so people are just
trying to find who's this Oliver Anthony
guy and what is he and where does he
work and who did he vote for and what's
his family like and yach because they
want to sort of build this um image of
whatever it is that the person behind
the song represents For Better or For
Worse people who agree with it want to
you know I don't know it's it's really
funny to watch on my end because
obviously I know what's true and what's
not and so like just what I've skimmed
through of people sending me
like like this like singing at the Super
Bowl like how many people have formed an
opinion about whether or not I should be
paid to sing at the Super Bowl like I'm
not singing at the Super Bowl that's
just a some somebody made up but you
know there's there's been hundreds of
hours that people's time wasted probably
talking about all these little like
things that don't even exist it's just
somebody made them up and put them on
the Internet and so I'm just letting
them ride I think they're I think it's I
think it's great I just think it's great
like that at least the last couple weeks
I've been able to entertain everyone and
get everyone's mind off like all the all
all the other horrible stuff that's
going on in the world right now like uh
at least everybody can have a good laugh
you know so well I mean it's it's a
subject of discussion so like everybody
is getting involved and and somehow or
another became cultural and then there
was uh Dwight from the office oh yeah
heck chimed in that if he was going to
write a cultural anth what did he say
something like he wouldn't write about o
overweight people on welfare he would
write about billionaires in their taxes
yeah there is nothing funnier than
millionaires talking [__] about
billionaires there is nothing funny
funnier about millionaires pretending
these billionaires are out of touch oh
yeah and then you know take take Dwight
from the office down to West Virginia
you know take them take them through
those coal mining countries take them
through those places in Appalachia where
people of extreme poverty and pills have
ravished those areas take them through
there and it's everywhere yeah the sad
thing is it's it's everywhere now it's
not you know it's funny people right off
the GetGo I guess because it was radio
WV that posted the original video but
like I've never once advertised myself
as being necessarily from the mountains
my grandfather grew up in western part
of Virginia the mountains but I've I'm
from Farmville which is technically
pedmont but even in throughout Ral
Virginia that poverty is a big issue and
drugs are a big issue and I mean it's
not just even in the rural areas and you
go into downtown Richmond or any
downtown anywhere for that matter it's
like it's almost like um yeah these
problems exist everywhere now that are
and I think I mean obviously they are
because that's why the song resonated
the way it did the problem for me was um
I knew that I needed to do this like I
knew I needed
to I procrastinated with music a long
time I mean I'm 31 I've been playing
guitar and singing on and off since I
was a kid like my my grandma was in a
band years ago and so like little I
remember as a little kid what got me
interested in all of it was um going you
know Dukes of Hazard when I was a kid I
was like five and I used to sit with my
grandma and we'd sit and watch J of
Hazard and watch Wayan Jennings pick
that guitar of course I had no idea who
Wayan Jennings was but that just like I
just fell in love with that and uh so
grew up listening to like that 70s
country and she loved all the old stuff
like the 50s and 60s and um even in the
70s even you know Janice and all that
and so like she really introduced me a
lot into music when I was a little kid
and so like I just kind of held on to it
but never never pursued it the way I
should and then I'd play at a bonfire
party or I'd play at whatever it's a
friend's house and everybody's like man
you got to do something with this you're
you know you don't want to waste this
Talent you've got and whatever and that
would almost make me feel even shittier
because I'm like oh man I suck like I'm
such a piece of crap for not doing
something with this and so yeah like
when I was outside of work it's like I
would just I would just i' drink I'd get
just absolutely stoned and I would just
sit around and try to think about
anything but what it was that I really
needed to be doing which was like and so
end it was kind of like funny but that's
ended up would kind of spark me into
like writing all these songs and doing
all this stuff cuz it's like I I don't
know just like with you probably with
some what you do Jiu-Jitsu or whatever
it's like for me songwriting is it gets
my head like you said getting your head
clear you know cuz that's all you can
and I songw writing is interesting for
different people but now that I've been
in the I guess now that I've been in the
industry for two weeks and I've talked
to like now that you've been in the
industry and conquered it now that I'm
an industry expert it's like some of the
other musicians I've talked to like the
people I've looked up to over the years
they experienc this too but certain
people when you saw song right it's a
very um it's a it's dramatic like um do
you write all your own songs yeah but
it's it's have you been accused of not
writing your own songs very early on
yeah because since my sta I guess it's
not even my stage name it's Oliver
Anthony music and so it's supposed to
represent music from you know Oliver
Anthony music as my my grandfather and
so he grew up in the 30s in the
mountains and used to tell all these
wild stories about how life was back
then but the music's just sort of a
characterization of like that period in
time and those people you know and
that's so yeah when when so your real
name is not all yeah Christopher
Christopher Anthony Lunsford is my real
legal name and so that's what's on like
like if you look up the songting why you
decide to sing as Oliver Anthony just in
um well like I said I have it I just had
the the YouTube channel listed as Oliver
Anthony music um just because like
that's sort of that's sort of the the
demeanor or the like I said the
character I was rep like that older
Virginia Style music like if you if you
look if you go on YouTube and you look
up that type of music from back then
like there's old recordings of people
like that's that's what I just love that
type of stuff you know you think you
going to keep that name yeah I mean I
mean a lot of people still call me Chris
and I've posted on social media call me
what I mean I've been called a lot worse
than either of those things but yeah
it'll it'll stay Oliver Anthony music
and definitely yeah it's a it's a it's a
special name and it's a special name to
me not only because it was my
grandfather's name but it's it's sort of
like to me it reminds me of how much how
different things were back then but uh
he was born Oliver Anthony but everybody
called him Anthony growing up and so
like he always thought his name was
Anthony Oliver and uh last name Engle
and so like it wasn't until he was in
his 60s and going to retire he realized
that his name didn't match his birth
certificant so he had to actually change
his legal name when he was in the 60s
but it's because back he thought his
name was Anthony Oliver yeah and so but
his legal name was and so it's yeah his
his parents named him so it's just like
but all but all the paperwork back then
was so scattered up because a lot of
people were illiterate and of course
documents weren't tracked as well as
they are now you know and so it's like
there's people in the family that have a
different spelling and it's the same
last name but the a few letters are
different and stuff it's just kind of
cool like but he just he just thought
that was crazy he had to change his name
and he was 65 so he could draw his
retirement all cuz his Social Security
and everything was under a totally
different name but that's crazy it's
it's just special to me um he was he's
like the only other one in the family
like me most of our family's like
average height 6 feet and under but he
and I were both you know 66 redheaded
left-handed like I just I don't know in
a lot of ways I just uh I I thought it
was special to kind of respect him he
passed away in 2019 and that's kind of
when I I guess that's when I first kind
of adapted the name for the music I
didn't really get serious with anything
until probably two weeks ago yeah till a
couple weeks ago probably until I think
I uploaded the first original like like
when I was when I decided I was in it to
win it and I really wanted to make this
thing happen um it was probably about
yeah probably May of last year when I
uploaded ain't got a dollar or it might
have been rich man's goal was the first
one I uploaded on YouTube but that's
when I decided like all right I'm I'm
doing this thing but yeah so you were
just smoking too much weed drinking too
much and just procrastinating yeah yeah
yeah yeah and so that and you know like
anxiety is is definitely something
that's underestimated you know I used to
laugh about not laugh about but I used
to just not really understand when
people talked about mental health and
anxiety because everyone gets stressed
out over stuff and so you think of
anxiety as being just like this normal
phenomenon everyone deals with but your
your mind can really put you in a dark
place to where that thing it just like
it just holds on to you like a you know
and it it just um makes it very
difficult for you to do anything and so
yeah I spent at least two years of my
life almost constantly just having what
felt like just a knot right here just
just wrenching at me well that's
especially true for people that are
pursuing a non-traditional life you know
with that doesn't have any guarantees
it's it's a wildli to try to be an
Entertainer like to Ju Just to choose to
try to make it in this wild world of
people that are singing and making songs
and you want people to pay attention to
you like do you know how many [__]
people are singing how many people can
sing how many people are recording
things and now with YouTube and and the
like how many people are putting stuff
up on the internet for other people to
enjoy it's a lot the idea that you're
going to stand out so that you're filled
with anxiety just because of that
because you're the future's uncertain
yeah I think for me a lot a lot of the
anxiety came from me just feeling like I
was running out of
time